hey guys how's it going so today is a
very exciting day today we are going
wedding dress shopping for
not me or jenna bray
bree i'm so excited i haven't seen you
in like forever i know look at bree's
nice dog carrier doggy car seat this is
gonna be me it is isn't it
yeah this is gonna be me i ain't playing
look at this little dog bone does he
like this uh this looks like yeah oh he
loves those really what is it it's good
for their teeth is this a chicken bone
um oh he eats it
yeah
well little man he doesn't eat his bones
he just like we don't have teeth yet
he's got teeth he's got sharks he's got
like ten they're not actual bones wait
what's a nylabone i have i got him in
nylabone you can't eat this
but it's plastic
oh those are bad too really
they had a recall on him and then he
doesn't like it anyway he just he
honestly like looks at it and he pushes
it aside i think this is pink he's like
okay what do you think about this for
your
wedding
we're looking for dresses do you want a
hat
do i want a hat will that look good for
the wedding is bree going to be sweating
for the wedding it's hot in 25
hot and cold is it yes or is it no
i'll give you a massage let me give you
a massage get away let me just give you
an aerial test look look how tempting
maybe because your purse is like
see you guys
oh my gosh you were like what is wrong
with you i know i know real tense
is that what you're doing
your hands up from my shirt yes
okay come on are you ready jenna's
peeing 75 75 off the deal i can't
believe what i just heard brienne loves
candy corn no one says you know what i
love candy corn except free why i love
halloween or the candy corn i'm real mad
at target because it wasn't out yet i
had to go elsewhere to buy my candy did
you have to go to walmart because guess
what i know for a fact they have it
because i was there the other day guess
what a whole entire aisle of it i had to
go to walmart to get my candy corn fix
they don't even know what's coming they
don't well actually they do because
you've been here
how many times have you been here
uh this is my third third time third
time's a charm i'm gonna have my dress
custom made by myself i'm gonna start
learning to knit
i'm gonna start knitting
no it'll look good on you that'll look
good on my finger on your finger wide
hips i feel like we're in like on the
show say yes to the dress i think we
might be we are we are we are we're here
saying yes to the dress
is there did you find another one you
might like free i think we should be
trying
to pick that one let's find
look actually that's really pretty
i think we might switch to 60 frames a
second one two three go everything is so
smooth
smooth dresses look at all these dresses
look at jenna just
wow
so today is uh bree's big day we're
we're looking for some dresses and we're
not going to show you the actual dresses
because we have to save it for the
second thing
all right
i'm a big fan of sort of the off-white
but this is a little too
that's very champagnish should we tell
brian about how amazing spanx are does
she know i'm not sure
we'll get her one as a present no
amazing
you basically put them on and it just
sucks everything no recipes
we're doing a little side-by-side
comparison here
i mean i like this one better but
which one do you like better i don't
know
they look yeah
different
i think this one looks
just hanging out back there don't worry
mine's not in the running
girl
no clearly
get out of here those hips don't lie no
you don't even have hips
oh excuse you excuse me you hello
but it's out of the running girl look at
that body we don't know that it could
still be in the running you work
out no no
let's put this one i'll swing a really
crazy one
we're looking i told them if they wanted
to pick me one i would try you know
which one i really wanted to try which
one right
here but it was definitely not what i
want it had like that lace back and it
was all like set straight
it's really pretty
yeah girl i like the
little alternating i like that a lot
look at that butt
actually she had that dress too because
of the same designer simple i took it
out for her to try she said no i don't
want to try it oh i like it it's really
good i really like it
the front it's okay actually oh look at
this the scandalous look scandalous
scan look at this excuse me we'll see
butt scan oh my goodness look at that i
can see your hip i can't believe you
want us to come home for this handle
i can't believe this candle
look it'd be like what's the hashtag
isn't it pretty
it is really pretty but it's too simple
it's yeah it's like not simple but like
it is but like the this part is i like
it and
yeah give us a profile
that's not a profile i don't know what
that means
yeah outside
oh gosh
bree little princess how many copyright
strikes are we going to get from all the
jams in here
tell the joke again i said for my
topless wedding i'm gonna have
this
i need help
look at my amazing instagram i blocked
out the dresses it is pretty good just
on the side so you can't actually tell
what we're wearing
i think
i found her dress wedding dress
oh man i can't wait for this wedding we
gotta start sweating for the wedding i'm
sweating already i almost passed out in
that dress honestly me too i was so it
was like hot too hot it was clipped i
couldn't breathe so look at paris just
getting ready
so brie found her dress but this is the
end of this vlog because we're about to
head to the steeler game so stay tuned
for that video or maybe i actually
already posted it and i'm posting this
later i have no idea my vlogs are never
in order but
that's just that's how we roll see you
guys later
up to date videos on my channel
what's your name i come home and i can't
think of anyone's names i am not well
all right i'll see you later peace out
i'm most excited to see about what my
dog thinks about it